[Musique]
avec non pour en parler si limagne vous
êtes infirmières scolaires en
loire-atlantique secrétaire adjointe du
syndicat national des infirmières
conseillère de santé également du snics
fsu à vos côtés frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste politique pour l'éclairage
justement politique sur ces actions du
gouvernement en la matière bonsoir à
tous les deux alors désormais un bientôt
en tout cas puisque là on en est à la
première lecture un proviseur saura si
un élève est vaccinée ou pas ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont été très inspiré
aujourd'hui comme abdoullah par exemple
qui est très remonté mais où va-t-on
vers un flicage généralisé je crois il
faut stopper cet élan sinon on va vers
la dictature même colère chez liliane
scandaleux la mission de l'école
l'enseignement et rien d'autre ce n'est
pas un lieu de soins surtout pour les
enfants en bonne santé et n'ont concerné
par le cos vide sylvie magne un flicage
vous partager ce sentiment de colère
en tout cas on partage un sentiment de
d'étonnement et d'inquiétude ce qui nous
préoccupe beaucoup en tout cas au
snics-fsu c'est considérer que les
parents menthe et qui
s'apparente pour nous finalement à une
rupture de confiance et à une position
assez agressif vis-à-vis des familles et
des élèves et c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on observe au quotidien dans les
établissements jusqu'à présent les
familles ont toujours fait preuve d'une
grande bonne volonté les familles
d'ailleurs comme la communauté éducative
et principalement les élèves aussi dans
la dans la manière dont ils l'ont
appliqué toutes les injonctions et
toutes les demandes qui ont été mises en
place depuis déjà presque presque deux
ans on a fait confiance aux familles
quand il s'est agi de garder les cole
ouverte on a obtenu leur adhésion à
toutes les mesures il y avait une
dynamique porteuse il y avait du sens il
y avait il y avait des valeurs autour de
ça et venir la rompre cette espèce de
pacte qu'on avait avec eux
effectivement nous ce n'est que ces
faits si on retrouve ça on trouve ça
préoccupant pour un bénéfice risque
voilà qui reste sans doute à démontrer
frédéric saint clair on entend ces
minima ne des secours voilà et très
audible c'est que onze en amont coûts
demandées là c'est l'imam parle de ce
pacte de confiance avec les parents mais
cet amendement il rend dans une loi plus
large e le pass sanitaire qui est encore
prolongé ce sentiment de voile a joué le
jeu et ça peut être la mesure ne troll
erreur politique
en réalité
j'aurais aimé vous dire qu'effectivement
c'est la mesure de trop et c'est
l'erreur politique de troubles mais ce
n'est pas le cas parce qu'on reste dans
ce pays pour une raison qui est
complètement incompréhensible dans une
forme de d'hystérie qui a saisi à la
fois le corps le corps politique les
français j'allais dire dans leur grande
majorité qui soutiennent ce principe du
pass sanitaires et puis surtout le
gouvernement et puis les instances de
régulation serrée instance de protection
des libertés fondamentales que sont le
conseil d'état le conseil
constitutionnel qui ont voté comme un
seul homme le pass and i ter en juillet
dernier donc si on veut comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer il faut et
comme vous l'avez fait faire deux pas en
arrière revenir au mois de juillet
comprend que cette quatrième vague qui a
flambé comme aucune auparavant a saisi
le gouvernement et l'a mis en état
hystérique et donc c'est pour ça que
cette violence faite aux libertés
fondamentales a été si soudaine et si
brutale et ça inquiète et manifestement
le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel qui ont dit
effectivement il ya un gros risque et
donc il faut valider cet empiètement sur
les libertés est cette discrimination
entre deux catégories de français ceux
qui sont vaccinés et qui pourront
adhérer
accéder à tous les endroits de la
société publique puis ceux qui ne le
sont pas et qui ne pourront pas et donc
en fin de compte le malaise qui se
créent par rapport à ces discriminations
et à cette espèce d'empressement du
gouvernement vouloir bien faire en
accumulant les lois en prolongeant pour
en parler un peu plus mais tout ça est
basé sur quoi sur une vérité médicale
révélé par le conseil scientifique
en tout cas prétendument révélée et on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il ay à division
dans le corps médical c'est à dire qu'
on n'est pas d'accord tous les médecins
le montre on n'est pas d'accord sur sur
un toute hâte détail par rapport à ce
vaccin par rapport aux bénéfices risques
et donc il ya aujourd'hui un problème
politique qui est appuyée sur une
incertitude médical et c'est ça le noeud
le noeud du problème il faut bien il
faut bien comprendre que tant qu'on
n'aura pas réussi à mettre au clair ce
qu'est ce vaccin est ce qu'il n'est pas
qui ils protègent et pour qui le risque
est plus grand que le bénéfice et c'est
le cas pour les enfants et bien dans ce
cas là on n'arrivera pas à tomber
d'accord et aujourd'hui finalement le
gouvernement touche du doigt c'est qui
est le plus précieux pour les parents
que j'allais dire les frontières le
général c'est l'institution scolaire et
puis c'est c'est les enfants de qui va
falloir je pense que le gouvernement
prenne la mesure de ce qu'il est en
train de mettre en place parce qu'il est
possible qu effectivement à terme c'est
à dire que si le l'épidémie venait à se
calmer
comme on l'espère tous et si cette
petite résurgence qu'on a vue
dernièrement ne prenez pas plus
d'ampleur il est possible qu
effectivement les noms de personnes qui
descendent dans la rue pour protéger
l'intégrité physique des enfants et ce
sanctuaire que l'école soit beaucoup
plus massif que ce qu'on a pu voir
pendant l'été la république en marchant
ps se défend aujourd'hui
je
pour oran verger un porte parole de
l'ars m objectif est tout simplement de
faciliter l'organisation de campagnes de
dépistage et vaccination d'organiser des
conditions d'enseignement permettant de
prévenir les risques de propagation du
virus et donc in fine et les fermetures
de classes elle rajoute aura en berger
c'est une mesure de bon sens silimane
sauf que voilà tout le monde ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille cette mesure de bon
sens
je sais une mesure pas dire que c'est
une mesure de bon sens alors que depuis
la rentrée scolaire l'école est ouverte
et que tout fonctionne plutôt
correctement les chefs d'établissement
ne sont pas particulièrement
demandeurs de ce type de mesure et ils
ne disent pas rencontré de difficultés
particulières en tout cas dans la
récupération
des informations qui sont nécessaires en
4k positif moi ça en tout cas ça nous
fait penser nous a à la mise en place du
pass sanitaires à l'école j'ai plus ou
moins à plus ou moins long terme et
peut-être plus à
un espèce de parapluies qu'on ouvrirait
pour pour cacher l'incapacité de l'état
à mettre vraiment en oeuvre des moyens
pour sécuriser l'espace scolaire
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'au niveau du
snics fsu on dit que pour ne pas fermer
de classes pour ne pas enlever des
enfants de l'école même quand il ya un
cas positif il serait bienvenu de
pouvoir
développer les équipes mobiles pour
faire des tests et pouvoir savoir assez
rapidement
quels sont les enfants qui doivent
rester chez eux plutôt que de fermer des
classes sauf que pour faire ça il faut y
mettre les moyens et ne pas tabler
uniquement sur les personnels de santé
de l'éducation nationale qui ne sont
déjà pas suffisamment nombreux pour
assumer leurs missions il faudrait aussi
que les familles puisse être
responsabilisés après tout ce sont les
premiers éducateurs de leurs enfants
une famille qui s'est
avoir pris un contact avec quelqu'un de
positif
pourrait très bien faire passer un test
naso pharyngé ou un test salivaire à
l'enfant avant de le ramener à l'école
il ya tout un tas de mesures qui
pourraient être mises en oeuvre et qui
serait sans doute moins moins
inquiétante en termes de libertés que
cette levée du secret médical on lève
aujourd'hui pour pour cette vaccination
on lèvera pourquoi demain je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui est préoccupant
et qui dit des choses sur la société en
ce moment et je partage assez ce que ce
que l'autre intervenant disait sur une
espèce de frénésie qui s'est emparée
avec une panique de voir ressurgir une
quatrième une cinquième vague alors
qu'on voit dans les faits que ça n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui en tout cas vous
êtes nombreux à réagir à d'instants gb
gbg il faut poser la question du
pourquoi faire les directeurs d'école
n'étant pas des médecins à quoi
peut-être leur être utile une telle
information purement médical à
discriminer à intimider à punir
effectivement la question devenue
pourquoi frédéric saint clair on a
écouté le développement de l'animal mais
en fait le scandale n'était pas plutôt
de 2 pouces et les enfants aussi jeunes
à la vaccination est ce que ça c'est pas
tout simplement voilà l'aboutissement de
ce qu'on avait demandé aux enfants quoi
qu'il arrive de la vie contraintes d'une
certaine manière de toute manière à se
faire vacciner son pagne de ne pas être
accepté dans des clubs de foot dans des
clubs de danse de toute manière il
n'avait pas le choix la le gouvernement
assume et va au bout de sa logique c'est
exactement ça le gouvernement assume et
va au bout de sa logique parce qu'il
sait que majoritairement cette hystérie
collective dont je parlais tout à
l'heure a saisi suffisamment de français
qu'il continue d'être favorable
aujourd'hui où passent sanitaire ça ne
sera pas le cas à jeu j'en fais le pari
ça ne sera pas le cas dans les dans les
décennies à venir on regardera
rétrospectivement cette séquence là et
on rendra raison à tous ceux justice
on rendra justice à tous ceux qui qui se
sont battus contre je parle bien du pass
annie terre et pas du vaccin il s'agit
pas d'être anti fax ici on parle
vraiment d'un problème politique un
problème d'amateurisme politique il ya
un problème d'hystérie qui consista à
instrumentaliser différentes catégories
de la population et les libertés
fondamentales pour parvenir à des fins
de régulation sociale donc en deux mots
ça signifie quoi ça signifie que sur les
enfants on sait très bien depuis le
début que premièrement les cas graves
sont extrêmement rares et que quand ils
sont quand les enfants sont contaminés
le
la contamination des autres enfants et
des adultes et je peux en témoigner
parce que j'ai vécu avec ma fille est
loin d'être évidente donc
fondamentalement la vaccination imposer
aux enfants est déjà une supercherie en
soi mais le fait de d'instrumentaliser
cela en créant
une fausse loi c'est à dire en créant un
système juridique qui va contraindre les
adolescents les enfants et même
d'ailleurs les adultes à se vacciner ça
ça contrevient à l'article 5 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
l'article 5 de restauration de l'homme
dit la chose suivante que nul ne peut
être contraint de faire ce que la loi
n'impose pas et on voit bien que c'est
pourtant ce que ce pass sanitaire fait
il nous contraint collectivement à la
vaccination alors que la loi ne
l'imposent pas donc le conseil d'état et
le conseil constitutionnel aurait
normalement dû se être vent debout
s'élever contre cette loi là ils ne
l'ont pas fait parce qu'ils participent
de la même un qui est une comme si
finalement cette épidémie a été si grave
et si menaçante pour la vie des gens
alors qu'on sait très bien depuis le
début qui mena qui elles menacent
toujours les mêmes personnes très âgées
avec d'écomobilité il faut comme si
cette menace était si grande pour nos
libertés qu'il fallait empiéter sur ses
libertés pour nous protéger malgré nous
il ya une rupture de confiance on l'a
entendu ce soir il ya un écrasement des
libertés fondamentales il ya une
discrimination et aujourd'hui il ya une
ingérence dans l'école qui encore une
fois non justifiée parce que les deux
médical prouve aujourd'hui les données
médicales pour certaines études prouvent
que ce n'est pas aussi évident et qu'il
faudrait être beaucoup plus prudent en
matière de juristes en matière de
jurisprudence c'est ce que le
gouvernement est en train de faire et
d'un point de vue légal et d'un point de
vue constitutionnel extrêmement
dangereux la ceni man vous avez tous les
deux commencé nos maux de confiance
justement la république en marge qui lui
l'enfant n'est pas sûr que les
déclarations qu'on nous font les parents
sur la vaccination de leurs enfants est
vraiment exact en gros on a peur quoi il
était content qu'on nous mentent ça vous
inspire quoi justement en tant que
délégué proche des parents
écoutez d'abord je voulais revenir sur
les conséquences et qui joue je vous
dirai ce qu'on pense effectivement de de
cette position face aux familles moi je
je je crains beaucoup ont toutes les
toutes mes collègues infirmières sur les
mêmes constatations les élèves ont
beaucoup souffert de ces deux années et
il ya eu un confinement une rupture du
lien social avec leurs camarades une
difficulté de se remettre au travail
quand on est content l'école a ouvert il
ya des conséquences qu'on voyait déjà
venir et qu'on est con et sur lesquels
on alerte est quasiment depuis
plus d'un an non seulement à court mais
à moyen et long terme parce qu'on n'en
n'est pas au bout et les jeunes qui
viennent nous voir dans les
consultations infirmières ces derniers
mois ne vont pas bien globalement y
compris des jeunes qui n'avaient pas de
difficultés particulières
précédemment à la crise sanitaire donc
le risque d'une stigmatisation par
rapport à leurs camarades fait face à
des décisions qu auront prises leurs
parents de vaccination ou non et pour
lesquels
voilà il se retrouve bien contraint de
faire avec c'est quelque chose qui va
rajouter encore du mal être dans une
situation pour la jeunesse qui est déjà
très très compliquée depuis des mois il
va falloir qu'on prenne soin d'eux et
qu'effectivement on arrête de rajouter
des couches successives de contraintes
et d'injonctions quand on en songe des
familles c'est ce que je vous disais en
préambule
nous on a des contacts réguliers avec
les familles on est conseillère de santé
en tant qu'infirmière de l'éducation
nationale auprès des chefs
d'établissement de la communauté
éducative dont les parents qui depuis un
an et demi ne savent plus trop qui vers
qui se tourner entendent des
informations diverses ont parfois des
discours discordants entre ce que leur
dit la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie quand quelqu'un dans la famille
ou dans les proches du réseau autour
autour d'eux a contracté le virus le
virus dako vide et qui entendent des
discours discordants entre la cpam les
agences régionales de santé et qui se
tournent vers les infirmières de
l'éducation nationale parce qu'on est un
professionnel de santé proximité qui
nous font confiance moi je crois pas que
les parents aient envie de mentir je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient envie de mettre
la santé de leur enfant en danger la
santé des camarades non plus et encore
moins la santé des adultes qui
travaillent dans les établissements
scolaires je pense que si si c'est le
cas c'est quelque chose de très à la
marge est en tout cas c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on a pu observer depuis des
mois où on est déjà sur du déclaratif
quant à un enfant était contaminé
jusqu'à présent la famille n'avait pas
de certificat à remettre mais simplement
une déclaration sur l'honneur jeu on n'a
pas observé de 2,2 flambée des
contaminations depuis que ça c'est en
place donc je peux pas je peux pas on ne
peut pas accepter qu'on mette en doute
comme ça les intentions et la parole des
parents en tout cas c'est pas les
relations qu'on a avec eux au contraire
quand quand il ya des cas qu'on les
appelle pour les alerter sur un cas dans
la classe ou par rapport à leurs enfants
ils sont enfin ils sont restés ifs dans
la majorité des cas est plutôt prêts à
tout mettre en oeuvre pour
entendre le message en tout cas frédéric
saint clair là on nous parle d'ailleurs
cette fois on parle de la troisième dose
qu'on ne sonnerait le passé ni terre ou
plutôt l inverse
il ya un moment jusqu'où va aller
l'acceptation des des français ce sera
ma dernière question
je le demande sérieusement je vous dis
depuis le début de cette interview je
répète que les français sont magiques
majoritairement favorables aux pass
sanitaire c'est dire à quel point
l'emprise la tyrannie qu'opère cette
épidémie sur les consciences et
excessive
une grande majorité de français a perdu
sa lucidité et croit que la propagande
je parle de propagande je pèse mes mots
la propagande gouvernementale et une
parole de vérité je vais vous donner un
seul exemple qu'il a été soulevée nulle
part le la loi qui vient d'être votée
prolonge la possibilité du pass
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 ce
gouvernement-là exécutif ne sera plus en
place en 2022 il ya des élections
présidentielles il y aura des élections
législatives à suivre on va valider une
loi d'exception qui place le pays dans
une situation d'urgence aucune situation
d'exception qui déroge au droit commun
jusqu'à une période où le gouvernement
n'est plus en place mais c'est mais
c'est impensable un truc pareil on peut
le faire avec une loi du droit commun
parce que cette loi de droit commun a
vocation à s'inscrire dans le long terme
et une situation d'urgence elle est
directement politique donc elle a
vocation à s'arrêter à partir du moment
le gouvernement n'est plus en fonction
donc on est dans une période
complètement folle en réalité ou à la
fois les dirigeants et les institutions
qui sont censés normalement opérées en
tant que contre-pouvoir ont perdu de
leur lucidité et ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que comme vous l'avez souligné une
grande majorité de français et dans ce
cas là aussi et donc nous sommes
minoritaires aujourd'hui en france à
ouvrir les yeux et à ceux d'hier mais en
fait nous vivons dans une situation
ubuesque c'est aurélien est
malheureusement quand on est minoritaire
dans une démocratie eh bien on n'a pas
la voix au chapitre donc on subit on se
mobilise mais on subit merci beaucoup à
tomber d'un frédéric à ça car ça fait
mal oui juste agité voilà je voudrais
juste ajouté pour conclure qu'il faut
savoir effectivement raison garder qu'il
faut protéger les jeunes parce que c'est
cela l'avenir c'est les citoyens de
demain et il faut il faut pas sacrifier
des générations ou pour des prétextes
qui ne se justifie pas voilà je vous
remercie merci vraiment c'est nous qui
ont vous remercions frédéric ça car
également